[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yep got a
good movie today we're gonna talk about
we finally got around to watching how
long ago was it louie that sent us this
yeah louis sent us this almost about two
years ago i don't know it was a long
time it was before we moved like
significantly before we moved yeah like
two years when did we move like last
september yeah
and i think he gave this to us
before the pandemic
yeah he might have two to three years
maybe
oops hard to say sorry well the thing
about it here's the thing
uh we actually were gonna review it like
not too long after we first got it and
like we started watching it and for
whatever reason
uh both of us were kind of like yeah i'm
not really feeling this
yeah it was just the first there's a
scene with jamie foxx and then that
[ __ ] black chick was in the back seat
of his car that was jada pinkett smith
you already appreciate it yeah okay i
thought it was i i was waiting for a
[ __ ] to smack a [ __ ] in this uh well i
haven't forgotten how old this movie was
yes so it's like i wasn't really used to
because i'm used to seeing her like more
recently or in like way older [ __ ] and
like this movie is like older than i
thought damn near 20 years 15 years i
think
yeah 2004 this came out i didn't realize
but yeah so for whatever reason we
started watching it a couple times but
we just i was just kind of like i don't
know i just wasn't really in the mood
for it but then the weird thing about it
because we're trying to go back because
i know that some of you guys have sent
us movies and we haven't got around to
that's why we finally did sexy beast
which you know which sophie sent us like
a [ __ ] million years ago i'm going
through all the videos we're trying to
go through all the ones and like i'm
like we're just kind of cover the ones
that we haven't done yet because i felt
really bad that sometimes they got like
put in the bottom of the pile or we
forgot and then we moved and then we
moved and stuff got like you know moved
around
and i'm finding videos now i'm like wait
a minute hold on where'd that come from
somebody must have sent us that so it's
starting to go in the it's starting to
go in the pile yes so we made like a new
pile so we apologize so if you did send
us a movie at some point that we haven't
covered we're trying to get to it like
uh recently yeah and like i said i was
trying to do something that i had as
well like twenty-five people would you
know hernandez or louis louis hernandez
he he [ __ ] i got a good relationship
with him on a movie level okay he sends
movies i don't know what it is with this
dude okay
he understands my tastes
everything he's [ __ ] sent me it's
like spot on
once i said it
i didn't realize he sent me collateral i
was watching had i known that he sent
that one
i probably would have put it the
priorities a little bit higher okay
because we got to it and then like the
jada pinkett smith [ __ ] scene comes
up where she's in the back of the car
and it's kind of slow
and
me and jane were both watching we did it
twice
yeah and there was something about
the the state of mind we were right at
the time were like i don't know if i
like this movie and then we switched it
off twice yeah because i was like well
it's like you know and the acting was
fine and everything like that but i was
like i don't really know if this is
going anywhere i thought this is not
going anywhere yeah and it seemed to
like go on for a long time but then
louie kept telling us it's like no you
have to keep going because it gets like
really really good and a bunch of you
guys had told us that too oh my god this
movie is so good yeah and i was like
there has to be a reason why
it was in so many and even back when it
came out in 2004 it was on like a whole
bunch of different like best like top 10
movies of the year and [ __ ] like that
and jamie foxx got nominated for an
oscar for best supporting actor so it's
like there has to be some reason right
uh you know so
last night we decided yeah there's some
setup and then there's the jaded picket
smith scene and then if you can get
through that which is only a few minutes
but there's something about it
and then right after that it [ __ ]
starts getting into it although last
night it didn't seem to bother me as
much maybe i was just like in a bad mood
that day
state of mind something like that
yeah because really they just kind of
set up there's like a really really
brief
sort of prologue that has tom cruise
with his gray hair going through the
airport and doing like a switcheroo bag
with jason statham yeah
yeah who does it does jason say them as
in this for like a bit part for like two
seconds yeah i don't remember how famous
was jason
that's what i thought he wasn't like
famous at this point in time
and uh and then it goes into the cab
scene with jamie foxx and jada pinkett
smith and they're talking to each other
and then that kind of goes along a while
but then like after that yeah it really
really picks up here's the setup
jamie foxx is playing
a cab driver
and he's the kind of [ __ ] that
just talks and talks and never does
anything all right he's kind of wasting
his life away
he has all these big plans but he never
acts on him
out of the blue
dude played a dude shows up played by
tom cruise
who's a [ __ ]
professional hit man
and he gets in the cab with him
and uh tom cruise and tom cruise look
let me tell you something
i won't talk about tom later bro okay
you guys know how i am with tom all
right it's tom and scientology
romance it's a slight bro
at least you're admitting it it's a
short guy thing okay we're about the
same size and we have a lot of the same
interests but the pat and we're almost
the same age a little bit older than me
but there's
[ __ ] turned out different for me and tom
because it's tom one and tom too okay
separated a bird separated from
anyway anyway
let me get it serious again okay that's
where we're going
tom shows up in this
and he's playing a [ __ ] assassin
working for some cartels
but he's really [ __ ] smooth
and he hires jamie foxx he doesn't know
jamie foxx the the cab driver doesn't
know that this is an assassin he says
look we need to go i need to make i got
this i got this whole route i got to do
yeah i got a bunch of stops and i'm
going to i got a bunch of stops and i
want you to hang out with me tonight i'm
gonna pay you [ __ ] 300 to do this 90s
how much would you make a night and he
goes i'll tell you when he ups it to
like 700 is what it ended up being
take me to all these places and we'll
hang out
that's what you're going to get tonight
and [ __ ] jimmy
and the cab driver
it's a part-time job for him he's not
even a full-time cab driver he he's like
okay she takes him to the first stop and
[ __ ]
the assassin tom cruise goes up there
and [ __ ] shoots a dude the dude falls
out the window [ __ ] jumps out he
didn't mean for that to happen right
yeah and it falls on the cab and busts
it and [ __ ]
and the cab driver sees it and realizes
that this dude's an assassin well he
kind of takes him hostage he's got no
way out he's got to go through this
[ __ ] mission he's got to kill how is
it four dudes five it's five people no
it's not all dudes uh it's five people
yeah yeah five people
and he's got to kill them all
and he gets four of them the last minute
doesn't get but you gotta see it
um and it's a [ __ ] good movie all
right it's kind of like a road trip
movie and a gangster movie
and with assassins and kind of like
james bond
type [ __ ] happens in it a little bit of
a noir vibe to it i feel like yeah
cops are in it fbi's in it a lot of cool
guns for the time
uh i think it's 2004 what it was it 2014
2004 this came out so real hot guns for
2004
uh tom cruise is carrying a [ __ ] hk
um i think it's a uh the usp [ __ ] 45
45 auto
which was that was a real hot
gun at the time and a bunch of [ __ ]
shows up [ __ ] smith and wesson
[ __ ] automatics and looking nine
millimeter [ __ ] full auto cult sub
machine guns you know ar15 or m16s of
nine millimeter full auto that the
there's cartels in it and
kind of almost
some of the a few of the scenes are
almost like somebody john wick
um
tom uh evidently went under went through
some trading uh by some sas guys
so i don't know why they always go after
these [ __ ]
sas dudes and this and that and [ __ ]
because really those guys are learning
from civilians civilian trick shots and
speed shots guys that have access to
[ __ ]
ranges and just don't do anything but
just [ __ ] shoot all the good day
but yeah i guess it sounds good on your
resume that's sas guys well yeah then
just i learned some [ __ ] from some brand
dude who's fast
yeah a dude that the sas goes to to
learn how to use yeah that doesn't sound
it doesn't sound the same but uh
yeah [ __ ] you see tom do some [ __ ]
really good fast fake shooting i mean
not live ammo wasn't involved but it
would have been good even if it was live
and
yeah it was a [ __ ] good flick real
good um well i like this because this is
one of the few times that i've seen tom
cruise play an out-and-out villain
and i think it works better for him
because it kind of like plays into his
natural assholishness yeah which which
is one of the reasons i don't usually
like him when he's playing the hero or
when he's like the star of the movie
because he comes across as kind of like
a [ __ ] to me like very cocky um but
the fact that he's like that makes him a
much better villain than a good guy i've
tom cruise is a much better villain than
a good guy yeah and seeing this movie
really cemented that i was like i i'm
glad that somebody had the balls uh and
this was directed by michael mann by the
boy the great michael mann who did the
insider he did
last the mohicans man hunter heat
um you know what i mean
uh he actually worked on the original
miami vice show as well uh so yeah so
this has like that kind of thing but i'm
glad that they finally
had him just play like a straight-up
villain
uh just like a cold-blooded sociopath
because i think that's really um
you know he pulled it off really well i
bought that
i bought that much more than i buy him
like as a good guy i know that's like
crazy on a roll the ethan hutch it does
depend on the roll uh i guess in
magnolia he played like a [ __ ] and
he was great in that too yeah uh not the
same kind of [ __ ] he wasn't that's
dick and eyes eyes wide shut and you
kind of buy he's not really a dick he's
just kind of like a he's not really a
good person in eyes wide shut yeah but
he's not really supposed to be a villain
no he's not a villain though yeah and um
interview of the vampire i thought he
was good in it he played a [ __ ]
arrogant ass vampire yeah
so any yeah so any role yeah i tend to
only like roles where they play into his
natural like arrogance yeah yeah he's
good at that but i think this is the
first one that he was an actual like
straight-up villain yeah but what's what
i did like about it is that uh he's an
enlightened villain he knows he's a
villain
and he's he quote he basically
says a lot of uh
a [ __ ] uh musashi-esque type
statements you know if you guys know who
[ __ ] shimon musashi was you know
and a lot of buddhist type stuff
like why are you worried about this
we're on a little bitty speck of dirt a
little ball called earth we're all gonna
die anyway
this is all temporary uh he starts going
through kind of like the uh the buddhist
ver the buddhist concept of like
enlightened indifference
of that this doesn't mean anything and i
know it doesn't mean anything it's all
just temporary you know we're all just
playing a role and we're just we're just
borrowing time here
uh [ __ ] which i thought that was very
cool
uh now jimmy fox in one scene goes okay
then i'm crashed the car which that was
great because that was the only way to
get to tom cruise was to crash the damn
question and that was i called him tom
cruise but what was his vincent was his
vincent was the character's name yeah
the only way you could do was by trying
to beat him by his own game you couldn't
go against him you had to go with him
he's like okay this doesn't mean
anything then i'm gonna crash well i'm
gonna crash the [ __ ] car crash the
car you go no no crash car [ __ ] but
like i thought you said it didn't mean
anything
yeah well that doesn't mean it doesn't
mean that vince's philosophy wasn't any
good because if this had a mission to do
he and he wanted his money and death
comes eventually anyway no reason to
rush it it's just that when it does come
oh well
uh you know but you want to delay it you
know i read that jamie foxx and tom
cruise weren't doing that cab crash uh
that they actually were in there like
they actually didn't surprise me they
actually pulled that off all right now
that's what i read i'm not entirely sure
now it's time for me to talk about tom
whenever i start talking about tom man
[ __ ] the fans go wild
okay and the fans go why because i know
a lot about tom cruise i know a lot
about [ __ ] scientology and everything
that happened i grew up watching him
[ __ ] i saw the damn oprah show where
he jumps up on the couch
i know i feel like everybody saw that
cult of sign cut scientology the free
winds and [ __ ] david miscavige and
and
and and going up the bridge and his ot
levels and everything and uh
i i know what tom went through
um
that's not the path i would have taken
but that was the path he took
so he tom is like the the number one
scientologist
good
he's like the best creation they ever
made
but he didn't get basic scientology he
got vip scientology
and uh i think it did kind of [ __ ]
help him like any training regimen can
help a person
um
tom didn't want to be a fake i mean
[ __ ] uh
you make a living pretending to be race
car drivers and [ __ ] gun fighters and
[ __ ] jet pilots and [ __ ]
but you just pretended
you know you're pretending that's not
what you are
and to get the street cred
tom couldn't join the military he was a
[ __ ] celebrity you know this wasn't
world war two where they drafted
celebrities you know
so really he went to [ __ ] scientology
and had a bunch of money and
they gave him the [ __ ] mindset i
think and and and
encouraged him to [ __ ] get that
training for himself so when you see tom
tonka ride motorcycles he can shoot good
he can [ __ ] fly aircraft he can do it
tom at least can do a lot of the [ __ ]
he's pretending to do yeah i do respect
him for that he does actually take the
craft seriously he will actually learn
to do the [ __ ] that he's like supposed
to be doing in the movie yeah tom's for
tom tom's competent okay he's not
pretending that's how he is is he
arrogant yeah yeah he's there everybody
knows he's arrogant
um yeah that's him that's kind of like
his trademark yeah uh i don't think he's
a bad person he i think he's a little
bit out of touch to the right with the
average person i don't think he's bad or
anything yeah i don't think he's a bad
person i just think he's kind of like a
cocky yeah he's cocky he's he's a cocky
bastard yeah cocky kind of out of touch
with the average person but the average
person really is kind of a [ __ ]
nowadays is kind of a [ __ ] couch
potato anyway so yeah you're gonna be
out of touch with the average is is he a
little bit [ __ ] hokey yeah he's a
little bit hokey
[Laughter]
uh he's not the kind of guy that you
want to [ __ ] take to a club and just
relax and you know get high with her and
he's not i don't think i could relax
around tom cruise no
he's more kind of like an army i feel
like he would get on my nerves
[Laughter]
it's kind of more like an army ranger
that's on [ __ ] duty all the time
so who you know you try to have to take
a vacation away from you know i'm like
oh man
yeah it's like
yeah okay dude you're a lot
[Laughter]
but he did a good uh he did a good job
on this move like i said i really kind
of like because he really does seem like
a sociopath yeah in this
movie there's some good scenes in it
yeah and i mean it's just really good
it's it's like it's a pretty
straightforward
narrative right but i really like the
way they just kept like upping the
stakes you know what i mean
and it was just like it was just [ __ ]
great like and all and it was like
really really good like with all the
tension and stuff like the first guy who
fell on the [ __ ]
cab and then you feel like i said tom
cruise didn't i keep saying tom cruise
he's an assassin um that he didn't mean
yeah victor vincent vincent vincent yeah
vincent he didn't mean for that to
happen no and so he's basically like
well we can't just leave the [ __ ] here
so we have to put him in the trunk
so then later on they're like driving
around with like a dead body in the
trunk of this cab and then drop his ass
off
yeah that was just kind of like
i don't know i kind of feel like
assassin 101 you might want to like dump
that in the river someplace or something
i don't know don't be like going around
especially because the car was like all
[ __ ] up from the dude like falling on
it so then the cops like pull them over
and they're like big tents kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i mean so
it's really really good the way it kind
of like ramps up the hilarious thing
about this i was like um
researching this movie
is that this
at least the idea for this movie
uh came like a long time ago
the guy that
came up with the original idea which
wasn't called collateral back then was
17 at the time
he got the idea to do the treatment he's
like an australian dude i think his name
is stuart beatty or something like that
he said i was like i was coming from he
was in sydney and he was coming back
from the airport and he's like for some
reason i'm in a cab and i just had the
re i just had the thought what would
happen if like you picked up somebody in
your cab and like that person was like a
psychopath you know what i mean so he
just kind of wrote like a two-page
treatment and then he was like kind of
um he met he came to la and he was like
kind of pitching the idea hbo were gonna
make it and then there were like all
these different directors interestingly
the one one director who was brazilian
wanted to make it more like a comedy
like the martin scorsese movie after
hours yeah and initially uh it was
supposed to be vincent was gonna be
russell crowe
and the cab driver was gonna be adam
sandler
okay which
yeah i don't know how that would have
worked out honestly i think it worked
out a lot better yeah you could make a
comedy [ __ ] about that about this you
could make a comedy version of this that
would work
um
but honestly i think it turned out a lot
better being kind of like more an action
thriller
type situation you know what i mean i
don't know
it would have been a completely
completely different movie had they gone
in a more comedic direction yeah i
wouldn't have liked it as much i don't
think yeah like i said you you know i'm
not just saying that you can't do that
you couldn't do this story comedically
because you totally could
um you'd have to make it like a dark
comedy that would work but i don't know
i kind of liked it better this way there
is yeah
sort of not a lot but yeah some there is
some there's comedy in it in the way
that it's not quite as funny to say die
hard but
die hard was an action movie that had a
lot of comedy in it not that but yeah
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] that happens
in it yeah
it's good
fourth row down says so did tom cruise
go out and kill several people to
prepare for this movie
yeah he would do some [ __ ] like that
i have to know what it feels like
method that's what i was gonna say
that's like method hectic now see that's
something that i ne that never uh that i
never actually thought of you know
you're kind of famous like method actors
like daniel day-lewis gary oldman and
people like that that get really really
into the wrong christian bale to a
lesser extent i just kind of feel like
yeah if they have to play like a
murderer in the movie they gonna insist
well i'm sorry to have to tell you this
but i'm gonna have to kill somebody
because yeah i can't play a person that
killed somebody unless i know what it
feels like in real life to draw human
blood yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
so did tom cruise become a vampire for a
little while too like
before he did it
i'll just pop over and become a vampire
for a little while and then i'll come
back to him he imagined it
he imagined but see that's the thing
about method acting though is you're not
supposed to imagine you're supposed to
have experienced it so you can use that
because i think yeah tom was a
scientologist by that time because i
think he became a scientologist during
during when he was [ __ ] filming days
of thunder
and that's when he became a
scientologist yeah it was right around
well was it a little bit before that
because i kind of feel like wasn't that
around the time that he married nicole
kidman yeah and he was trying to like
get her into the cult too i've never
seen days of thunder
i've heard it's kind of meaty i remember
not liking it i kind of feel like i
don't even remember how i would have
ended up watching i didn't pay to watch
it or anything like that but maybe i
just like watched it when i was on cable
and i was kind of like i feel like
everybody because i'm from daytona beach
and i feel like everybody in daytona
beach like it was the law like you had
to watch it because it was like about
nascar and yeah daytona is like a big
nascar kind of [ __ ] but
i don't even remember if i sat through
the whole thing because i was like oh
boy nascar and tom cruise doing my least
favorite things yeah you know what i
mean i just remember it being i'm sure
it's fine um
it just wasn't really my thing you know
what i'm saying yeah but i don't really
hear a lot of people talk about it
anymore not the same way that they talk
about like top gun or something like
some of his really yeah early like
risky business like slasher fred just
said i just kind of feel like yeah i
kind of feel like it was one of those
ones that it was just kind of like fine
but
yeah you know i don't know i'm just
going to say it's a real good movie it's
a good gangster movie that kind of
action adventure
has a lot of good uh messages in it kind
of deeper philosophical messages about
you know how to spend your time while
you're alive
um
has some really good scenes in it
and tom playing a bad guy and he's a
better bad guy than a good guy oh i
definitely agree with you on that yeah i
mean he should play more sociopaths
right and i like that they kind of made
him look not tom cruisey yeah like they
made his hair gray and kind of
big
yeah you know it's not big kind of
prematurely gray though
yeah
like it looked like salt and pepper yeah
it looks kind of fake to be honest
but it's it's still good he still looks
cool in it and the thing about it is
that they were saying well his character
and even like in universe like of the
movie he was supposed to be
uh
just like not
even the dudes that hired him like
didn't know what he looked like right
you know what i'm saying all they knew
was his first name
so he was like real down with his
anonymity but then like meanwhile goes
and like shoots up an entire like
[ __ ] downtown like los angeles
nightclub going after this one guy
where and everybody saw him he's
interesting he's an interesting
character i mean like uh he's pretty
well cultured real educated
uh knows a lot about music and stuff and
can be real cool with you and talk with
you before he kills you yeah that one
scene in the jazz club was actually
really good
i was not expecting that yeah he can
like you and still kill you
so he's like hey that's what they pay me
to do yeah sorry
so it's not it's not real personal to
him yeah he's not like a serial killer
he's just very cold-blooded he's like
hey they paid me to do the job so i'm
gonna do the job he's compartmentalizing
yeah exactly that's exactly what he's
doing and the thing about it is that
even though he's obviously the villain
he's obviously a bad guy
but
in a way he does help even though he
puts poor jamie foxx like through the
[ __ ] ringer um you know and actually
jamie foxx gets
uh
through this whole convoluted series of
events where they think that he's the
hitman and start like kind of following
him and he kind of gets shot at and [ __ ]
but
it does actually kind of end up helping
him out in a in the end because it makes
him see well
you know because his whole thing is he
has this dream he drives a cab but he's
like oh i have a dream to like open up
my own limo company and i have all these
ideas and all this stuff but it's like i
haven't i don't have the money or i
don't blah blah blah and he's been
driving the cab for 12 years and
basically this whole this one night
because the whole movie takes place over
one night he's basically like oh well
[ __ ] if i want to do something with my
life maybe i should just like get off my
ass and do it instead of you know so it
did actually make him
come out of his
fear of failing or fear of like moving
on to the next level or of whatever so
it did like actually help him out in
that way so i thought that was kind of
cool too you know but yeah this is uh
i'm glad we finally got around to
watching this and i have no idea because
when we were watching it last night
i wasn't bothered at all by like the cab
scene it didn't seem slow it didn't say
it was interesting and then i was like
what the [ __ ] was the matter with us
like that we sat we put this on two
times in like the first five minutes we
were like man
you know i don't know i don't know what
it was maybe we're just in a bad mood
both of those two times and we just
couldn't get because it didn't bother me
at all last night i was like all right
i'm down well i think just going into it
not knowing what kind of movie it was
is part of it too yeah you know i didn't
know what kind of movie it was i didn't
know anything to do with any kind of
assassins or anything tom cruise didn't
seem to be in it uh from what i was
watching i just didn't i just didn't
know anything about it so i think had we
seen a trailer for it and then why it
would have been a little bit different
it just seemed to be kind of slow
yeah you know but the thing about it is
that like that openings yeah that
opening scene it did seem initially like
to go on for a while but then that that
ends up being important like at the end
of the movie so it's not like it was
just there for no reason you know she's
in the cab talking yeah and you're like
uh and you're just kind of like well is
this like does this go anywhere is this
germain to the situation but it is
actually it does actually end up being
important later on and it kind of like
comes full circle so there was a reason
why it was there
a bunch of people are recommending
tropic thunder which i can't believe
that you've probably never seen tropic
thunder that seems that seems like a you
movie is that the one where they were
pretending to be in vietnam
yeah yeah yeah isn't that tom cruise is
in it and robert down junior's in it
yeah that's the one that's like you
don't go full [ __ ]
yeah that's that one and uh yeah that
movie is [ __ ] hilarious you and it's
it seems like right in your wheelhouse
it seems like you'd really really find
it ever since santa yeah you we should
probably do that one of these days
because that movie is [ __ ] hysterical
but uh yeah that was enough that was
another good role the type and i'm not
saying i hate i don't i don't hate tom
cruise um you know it's just i'm never
all that enthused to see movies that
he's in but there are like some movies
that he's been in that i actually really
like somebody talked about the edge of
tomorrow which i think we saw that that
was good what was that other one
oblivious
yeah oblivion was good he was good in
that like i said he was good an
interview with the vampire he was good
in magnolia i liked him because he
played a [ __ ] in that i liked him as
ethan hunt in all the uh
the mission impossible movies and they
got better as they went yeah mission
impossible fallout was actually pretty
great
uh yeah i really liked that as well but
you know he's he's not my favorite actor
but
you know he he's good in in certain
things he's good in certain times you
know he jumped up on the [ __ ] table
and they started beating him up with
scientology and [ __ ] so it kind of
[ __ ] up his
his persona
and uh
you know not as bad as not as bad as
[ __ ]
not as bad as [ __ ] steven segal but
you know i mean he started to become a
meme
so the the tom cruise meme overtook some
of his [ __ ]
actual work his work is good real good
well the thing about tom cruise is that
stories started to emerge well yeah and
it kind of kind of kind of tarnished
his public image in a certain way but i
think unjustifiably
just go watch his movies there you know
his work is good
and i think he's a good person i think
he's just uh
well
some people saying that the
scientologist can't be a good person
that it makes you a [ __ ] psycho
uh
maybe yeah
having hung out and worked with like a
lot of scientologists it does kind of
like dicks i've run into it it does uh
kind of like [ __ ] up your thinking in a
particular way that does actually make
you really assholey yes so scientology
is literally a paramilitary situation
and they're in there forever they all
think they're especially if they're in
the sea org they think they're [ __ ]
army rangers or something well and they
think that they're better than everybody
else too it's a very
complicated it's yeah it's very
hierarchical it's very like we're
superior to everybody else oh you poor
they call them dogs yeah uh you poor
wogs that aren't enlightened like we are
we're the only ones that can do this and
i really don't like people like that so
and that and scientology really
encourages it the thing about it like
putting scientology aside i think the
problem that tom cruise has which is
nothing to do with scientology is that
he's too famous i mean you get into a
thing you go into acting whatever and
some of like get super super famous and
he's like this big celebrity but there
comes a point where your persona
overtakes your work so i kind of feel
like tom cruise maybe not so much
nowadays because he's older but for a
while tom cruise the movie star was so
famous that he couldn't disappear into a
role you would see him in a movie and
you're like oh it's tom cruise he's
playing himself playing it and that was
always what he did he couldn't like play
a character you couldn't forget that
that was tom cruise because he was so
[ __ ] famous and because you got the
sense that he was always kind of playing
himself to a degree they're talking
about will smith and everything going
yeah
it's obvious it's obvious to me
being a harbinger of the future and the
nostra thomas i can see how it going
the era of the movie star is over all
right [ __ ] will smith [ __ ] helped
end it
but there are some people that will die
movie stars
okay tom cruise is one of them tom
cruise is a [ __ ] movie star yeah and
he'll die a movie star even if movie
stars are a thing from the past
and they are okay new movie stars are
not really being created
um
it's just not in the culture anymore
nobody cares like rock stars rock stars
i mean the thing is there are people who
are famous enough that a lot of people
have heard they are they're not a movie
star but it's you know you i feel like
nobody like a lot of people don't have
like the ubiquity yeah that tom cruise
like every [ __ ] knew it's probably in
the [ __ ] on the [ __ ] globe like knows
who tom cruise is he's one of the last
final movie stars but yeah just like i
was saying rock stars they don't make
rock stars anymore
they're gone there are rock stars but
they're aging
well and there are rock stars to
particular segments of the population
like i said everything's kind of become
like smaller and more yeah which is not
the same as being that's not the same
well and like i said it's not the same
as everybody on earth like you know
everybody on earth knew who eddie van
halen was when he was a rock star
everybody you know [ __ ] everybody
knew who [ __ ] michael jackson was he
was a pop star but that's also a rock
star yeah same thing
those things are gone now yeah uh
they just don't have the staying power
the medium of entertainment is not the
same and it's too compartmentalized now
it's not right we're not all seeing the
same thing and that thing because
everybody's just kind of like like i
said you know now it's very easy to kind
of just stay in your own entertainment
because [ __ ] there's
like i said i'm really into horror and
[ __ ] like that i could live the whole
rest of my life and watch nothing but
horror right and not even see any other
because there's so many
you know and not even see any other
genres i wouldn't do that because i like
other other genres of movies too but i
could do that if i wanted to so
and so could anybody um but yeah so this
definitely definitely one of tom
cruise's uh
better films yeah uh better performances
just because he's playing
like i said a psychopath would you read
what mango says be honest [ __ ] tom
cruise was in some fantastic movies he
was yeah you might like magnolia as well
i haven't seen it for a while but yeah
that's a really really good that's
that's a [ __ ] great movie yeah um but
yeah so
like i said he's been in some great
movies i'm not saying that it's just
that
a lot of times i feel like he's just
playing himself i've never ever seen him
in a movie but that's what they hired
kind of yeah like where i forgot that
was tom cruise you know what i'm saying
whereas some actors i can see him in a
movie and i forgot that that was like
that actor you know what i mean in that
era that's what they were looking for
yeah they hired tom cruise because he's
a big draw everybody's going to come and
see him just because tom cruise to be
tom cruise in the movie playing a
character yeah that's yeah think about
collateral i didn't realize like i said
not not only did i
not realize that this was as old as it
was 2004 for whatever reason i also uh
didn't realize that javier bardem was in
this he's only in like one scene i love
him by the way um and mark ruffalo is in
this too like he's only in a couple
scenes he plays like one of the cops or
the fbi guy or something like that
that's investigating like why all these
people are getting killed but yeah i
mean
so so definitely thank you louis for
sending it and i'm glad that we finally
like got around too got around to like
our impatient bad mood asses to like
actually sit there and watch the [ __ ]
thing instead of being all [ __ ]
grumpy about it because it actually was
like a pretty [ __ ] great movie and i
was like really really entertained um
but yeah and i feel really bad because
oracle just got here and we've we're are
like
wrapping it up unfortunately mega says
tom cruise would have been great in uh
boogie nights yeah he probably would
have not maybe not as dirk diggler
but maybe in like another role yeah
because i can't see anybody but uh but
wahlberg again
because he has like such a yeah he has
such an interesting like he's real cocky
but he's also kind of like childlike and
dorky at the same time and i feel like
that was perfect for that role we got a
bunch of movies too they were very good
man [ __ ] i liked [ __ ] uh that one
about the florida guy the painting game
yeah he has a very very particular
there's a certain thing he can play yeah
that he's really really good at you know
what i mean and like i said the dirk
diggler role was right in there and pain
and gain was right in there somebody
who's kind of like sweet and but also
kind of like naive and also kind of an
idiot
you know what i mean it's just it's
really hard to describe but yeah he's
usually good at those uh yeah the sister
christian song scene yeah that was
[ __ ] great all right uh oracle says
no worry is my own fault for not showing
up until now yeah sorry about that we're
uh we're getting kind of hungry because
it's dinner times we're gonna go make
some fish tacos yeah and uh shut it down
and then okay i will so uh yeah tomorrow
night uh is our regular show and we're
doing show about the dc snipers
so
that should be entertaining uh so
everybody drop by tomorrow night 6 p.m
eastern standard time for that one and
uh we will see you guys again tomorrow
evening
bye